[موسيقى]
في باريس توجد مدرسه ليست كباقي المدارس
ينشا فيها الاطفال على الموسيقى منذ 75
سنه يساهم فرع متخصص في اذاعه فرنسا في
تكوين الشباب والاطفال يصير مغني ضمن فرقه
الكره الى الفرنسيه
[موسيقى]
قبل حفل موسيقي كبير يقوم هؤلاء الشباب
بتدريبات اخيره تحت اشراف اداره الكورال
فاذا امعدت من نظر جيدا وحفظتم على الثقه
في النفس والقدره على اقناع الجمهور تحت
اشراف القائد سينجح الحفل الى الصفحه 68
69 الغناء كممارسه الرياضه لابد من
التدريب والتسخين هنا نعمل على تسخين
الاحبال الصوتيه كنت ايضا بتنبيه البنات
على التركيز على بعض النقاط وعدم نسيانها
اثناء الحفل
بعد عده ساعات ستحقق هؤلاء التلميذات
حلمهن سيؤدينا جنبا الى جنب مع الاوركسترا
الفيل الهرمونيه لراديو فرنسا سيمفونيه
بيرليوس قطعه موسيقيه تتطلب اداء دقيقا
التوتر وليس الخوف سيكون هناك الكثير من
الناس اضافه الى الكاميرات والقائد
الاوركسترا والاوركسترا
التوتر حاضر والادرينالين سيكون عاليا ان
صحته
فروع في ضواحي العاصمه
مثل مدرسه مدينه بوندي باقليم سانسندوني
هنا بدات تعلمها
تخلفها الان كريستي في التاسعه من العمر
تتلقى تعليمها من مرجان قائد الكورال في
مدرسه بوندي
جيد
انظروا الى حركتي
نغني الان مع القيام ببعض الحركات
في مدرسه راديو فرنسا نقوم بالتركيز على
الاداء الجماعي بشكل خاص
الغناء ضمن الكره يعني القدره على العمل
ضمن الجماعه انطلاقا من المرحله التعليميه
سواء ضمن دروس الغناء او دروس البيانو
يتعلم التلاميذ مع بعضهم البعض انها مدرسه
حياه بكل
بعد درس الغناء لا راحه للمتعلمات
الصغيرات انه وقت تعلم المبادئ النظريه
للموسيقى هناك خطا في احدى الخرجات التي
يقوم بها معلمو مدرسه الغناء للبحث عن
المواهب تم اختيار كريستي من مقاعد
المدرسه الابتدائيه لتلتحق بمدرسه الغناء
فصارت الفتاه الصغيره منذ ذلك الحين مقسمه
بين المدرسه العاديه في الصباح وتلقي دروس
الغناء بعد الظاهره
[موسيقى]
اتجاه هكذا مرح نوعا اما هذا الصوت
فنتيجته هكذا
برنامج مكثف لكن طفله الصغيره مستعده لرفع
التحدي
[موسيقى]
نقوم بحفلات موسيقيه كبيره في فرنسا
نلتقي بالعديد من المشاهير الذين غنوا في
اكبر الاوبرات
نسور الكثير من الامكنه التي لا نتمكن من
زيارتها بصفه عاديه
ثم نغني امام جمهور واسع
الا تخافين حين تقفين امام عدد كبير من
الناس لا انا اعلم انهم جاؤوا الى هنا من
اجل الاستماع الينا لذلك لابد من الغناء
جيدا حتى لا ينزعجوا
لا منصه من الاجتهاد لتحقيق الحلم حين
تعود كريستي في المساء الى المنزل تفتح
البيانو الخاص بها لتقوم بواجباتها
مواظبه على التعلم وفخر للوالدين
قدمت لنا معلمتنا ايزابيل قطعه موسيقيه
لكن علينا نحن ايجاد الكلمات
دوسيلا
انها تعتمد على نفسها ومتحمسه للغايه
ولسنا بحاجه لمقدمه لها المساعده
يقدمون لهم برنامجا محددا ويطالبونهم
بالمواظبه على العمل والتعلم دون انقطاع
تعلم القصائد وحفظها في المدرسه
يساعدنا على حفظ الاغاني بشكل اسرع
في غضون سنوات قليله ستتاح لكريستي ايضا
فرصه الاداء الموسيقي مثل قريناتها في
قاعه عرض كبيره نعود الان الى مبنى راديو
فرنسا حيث تقترب ساعه الحفل الكبير الكره
على اتم الاستعداد واندريليا كذلك
حان وقت النزول الى الكواليس والدخول في
دقائق طويله من الانتظار لكن الفتاه
المتحمسه لا تبدو متوتره
بما تشعرين الان متوتره اليس كذلك
لا ابدا
الفتيات الشابات الى الخشبه الان تحت
تصفيقات القاعه الممتلئه وسرعان ما يرتفع
الصوت الشجي بشكل متناغم
تغمرني سعاده كبيره ويرتفع الادرينالين
لديه حين اقف في حفل كبير امام الاصدقاء
والاهل والجمهور الذين لم يروت ابدا تغني
انها فرصه لنثبت لهم اننا قادرات على ذلك
انا فخوره لاني من ابناء هذه المدرسه
الموسيقيه كل سنه تمنح مدرسه الكورال
لراديو فرنسا الفرصه ل 160 شابا وشابه من
سن السابعه الى الثامنه عشره تمنحهم
الفرصه لينشؤوا في حضن الموسيقى ثم يحقق
الحلم ممارسه فن مفعم بالمشاعر
[تصفيق]